we begin this half hour with a
relative history revived by the pandemic
if you walk through some italian cities
you'll see a curious design feature
windows that can discreetly open to
serve food and drink to people on the
street
now in the renaissance capital of
florence those
wine windows are back in service chris
livesay shows us why
good morning from florence a city that's
no stranger when it comes to pandemics
throughout the centuries it survived
successive waves of the plague and now
that experience
is coming in handy especially when it
comes to wine
in a city as jaw-droppingly beautiful as
florence you'd be forgiven for
overlooking this
or this more than 150 so-called
wine windows tiny hatches dating back to
the renaissance
now in the covet age they're having
their own rebirth
i think it's it's great and it's a way
to social distance i suppose
bouquet del vino as they're known in
italian were likely invented as a way
for noble families to discreetly sell
wholesale wine in small portions says
historian diletta corsini
they're really all over the place aren't
they
the tiny openings prevented merchants
from selling in bulk
but as corsini discovered they acquired
another use
during the black death merchants
specifically use them
to socially distance from customers on
the outside
according to this medical book from the
1600s
so they never came in contact with each
other that's what the wine window did it
created that distance
between the buyer and the seller an
anti-plague safety measure
forgotten over the centuries that is
until florence's
most recent plague covet 19 and history
repeated itself not stopping at wine
gelateria vivoli was one of the first to
reopen
its buquetta so here's how it works
you let them know you're here you tell
them what you want
you pay
and out comes your ice cream
irresistible to florentine's fresh out
of lockdown
says owner sylvana vivoli so the idea
worked
yes yes once we really have a really
long queue bars and restaurants caught
on
now reopening wine windows long sealed
shut
like the osteria belledonne hey come on
like why do you want to open it
once the worst hit country in the world
italy now ranks among the healthiest in
terms of new coronavirus infections
businesses can now open their doors but
if this modern day plague locks them
down again
some can open their windows
now the plague of 1630 lasted three
years history shows that pandemics have
always been tough to beat but history
also shows that social distancing
is effective for cbs this morning
saturday chris livesay
florence i like the idea of just walking
up randomly to a window on the street
and saying i'll have ice cream i'll have
wine
sure take it have wine